lawyer and Harvard Professor Alan
dershowitz sat down with Fox News Sean
Hannity discussed the former president's
legal prospects suggesting that while he
would likely be convicted the ruling
would be overturned by the Supreme Court
quote they claim that Donald Trump
actually believed that he lost the
election that everything he did was
fraudulent that he conspired with
unnamed lawyers to affect the election
you're allowed to challenge elections
indeed the best way to challenge
elections is to come up with a slate of
alternate electors the government has
the burden of proof Beyond a reasonable
doubt that subjectively Donald Trump
actually believed that he lost the
election and acted contrary to that
belief there is no Smoking Gun there is
no one who is credibly prepared to
testify that Donald Trump said to him I
know personally I lost the election
what they're doing the indictment is
they're taking things where Trump said
like you're crazy to someone as if to
imply that means he really knew that he
did lose the election but more
importantly I'm not so sure how much any
of this procedural stuff matters